بعد اطلاق حزب الله صواريخ تقول الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه انه تم اعتراض ثمانيه منها من
بين 18 صاروخ اطلقت في الجليل
الغربي نعم يعني عمليات متتاليه ومتلاحقة
راس الناقوره في الجليل الغربي الدفاعات
الجويه حتى اللحظه اعترضت فقط ثمانيه
صواريخ ما يعني ان هناك 10 صواريخ لربما
سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه
او تسببت باضرار ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
المعلومات لا تزال واضحه حول بقيه
الصواريخ التي لم يتم اعتراضها هل تسببت
باضرار ام انها سقطت في مناطق مفتوحه هذا
الامر ياتي ايضا في اطار رصد صباح هذا
اليوم ايضا اكثر من 10 صواريخ اطلقت
باتجاه مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه في مزارع
الشمعه ولكن ايضا في ذلك الحدث لم يتم
تسجيل اي اضرار ولكن نرى ان حزب الله بات
يشن عمليات اكثر تطور واكثر تصعيد خاصه
البارحه نحن نتحدث عن اصابه تسعه جنود
اسرائيليين بجروح متفاوته ما بين خطيره
ومتوسطه
وطفيفة فهم مره اخرى وايضا تكرر ذلك الامر
في مزارع شبعه يوم امس وبالتالي نرى ان
هنالك منحى اخر يتم اتخاذه في هذه
العمليات وهنالك تصعيد لوتيربرونين
لبنانيين وبالتالي ينعكس هذا الامر عسكريا
على المواجهه هنا في الجبهه الشماليه
المناطق القريبه من راس الناقوره في
الجليل الغربي ايضا تم اغلاقها بشكل شبه
كامل نتحدث عن تحويلها ايضا لمنطقه عسكريه
يمنع من الطواقم الصحفيه حتى الاقتراب من
هناك وبالتالي هنالك ايضا رقابه مشدده على
ما يحدث في الجبهه الشماليه من تطورات
وبالتالي فقط المصادر الرسميه هي التي
تقوم بنشر المعلومات طبعا هذا الامر يشير
الى احتدام الموقف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
قامت باطلاق عده قذائف باتجاه بلده
الناقوره اللبنانيه كنوع من الرد على
مصادر اطلاق هذه الصواريخ ايضا كان هنالك
رد من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه على
القذائف التي اطلقت باتجاه مزارع شب
وبالتالي نرى ان اسرائيل ايضا تقوم بالرد
بشكل سريع جدا على مصادر اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ وهنالك لربما تعتبر هذه الرش 18
صاروخا هي الاكبر منذ بدء هذه
المواجه فاطمه خميسي مراسلتنا من الجليل
الاعلى شكرا
لك